I love the Black Panther movie children
here
[Applause]
pretty fast walk in here so yes I live
in a van
thanks Riley please Hospital actually
gonna head I have to run Dave and mother
I'm a ti-liger creatures I am offended
sir - David vipers like how very people
say communism never works as if we
didn't spend billions of dollars and
kill billions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work I remember the war I'd be
pretty angst about it now
Tommy there's a number works because
whatever people control the means of
production they're democratically like
the leaders miss you sometime this fall
rubber group always finds automatic
weapons and look to hang themselves way
to stabilizer yourself lady
all four lights on and working good luck
trying to pull me over in the south now
boys
I'm untouchable comic but before I've
been on laughs on Fox I have my own
podcast and let's just say these jokes
are vetted I keep it real up here right
now at 9:30 a.m. in the middle of
[ __ ] February there are no leaves is
leaf Boyd three leaves around just gonna
[ __ ] it's picking up with your hand
dude some of us are sleeping in their
cars man consideration you see that
he's left literally like five leaves
he's blowing it's gonna whole [ __ ]
backpack just to move five leaves that's
all the leaves in the park just gathered
all the buff I am at the nation's
capital Washington Monument so guys I'm
here at the Washington Monument
at least popular window
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right how about being fake walk all
right thank you depending over whether
they get you keep asking me which city I
like the best they can write bad jokes
anywhere next comic is visiting us from
New York City please give it up for Hans
Tim thank you ladies and gentlemen my
name is Hans camp and I work in a sushi
restaurant
I'm in the great American city of
Baltimore this is a whole other American
city that I'm in it looks like the Joe
Pesci of city's top it's like we've been
through a lot and we're a little small
but we got a lot of fight in us your
next comic coming to stage he is on tour
across the country be assisting us from
New York City and all sorts of places in
between please welcome the stage the
very hot stand everybody thank you guys
it's good to be here
my name is Hans Kim and have a stand up
comedian
I feel validated I feel see Santa Kali
is where you use happiness to tell
people why you're sad because I do
stand-up comedy I wish I was a painter
because I've never been painting a
picture of the canvas do you like draw
something Asian painting
you know I'm having a hard time getting
bucked I have to be down the friends on
Facebook but no one will work me I'm
pretty popular because as we all know
the best company's got some nice people
who have what really likes no it pokes
me and I figure they're wise because
everyone who book shows only books
they're friends and then my friends book
based on Mary coming in some of these
shady friends huh I don't want to make
it because I work hard anyone can do
that
[Applause]
good primordial personality hey guys I
didn't do any workout myself reward such
an artist respect to the Jews that my
favorite just all Jews system is broken
man it's good to be here
[Applause]
[Music]
just dust guys Asian women you guys
might like you're such hot [ __ ] but back
home we're throwing it away
you look like us I could throw it away
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hey I'm here with Kay Belle what makes
DC the hottest place to be a young
comedian nowadays I don't know if it's
the hottest place but it's pretty decent
you got mics every night you can't have
multiple mics a night with you a lot of
people in there so what is your whole
shoe situation like right now yeah is it
like hard to take off or is it because I
can lay down some cardboard we don't
need it you don't need to be taking
pictures of the zoo
[Music]
joke
[Music]
I saw do during a book in Arabic at an
airport which kind of freaked me out but
then I saw the folded corner of the page
I put the puck away and I was like on
that guy he's got future plans how's the
call son
in their own instruction is the
beginning middle and an end to that he's
gonna want to finish that book up